huge numbers of Americans are traveling
for the 4th of July holiday that's
tomorrow
triple-a says nearly 49 people people I
think it's gonna be a bit more than
let's just get with with the word people
how about that but you're right it'll be
a little bit more than 49 million
49 49 million people are planning to
travel by car thank you Tony train and
plane that's up more than four percent
from last year now the vast majority are
going to drive Kris Van Cleave is on the
road in Virginia this morning Chris so
when are the best in the worst times for
people to hit the road good morning
right now is not one of the better times
and certainly this afternoon between
3:00 and 7:00 is not the time to hit the
road but the absolute worst will vary a
little bit by where you live if you're
in New York Detroit San Francisco Los
Angeles you'll see the worst of the
traffic today in other cities like
Atlanta Boston Chicago you'll see brake
lights start to build Friday and in DC
drivers will get the worst of it on
their way home on Sunday an estimated
forty 1.4 million Americans will be
driving it feels like many of them are
on this Virginia freeway right now low
gas prices are a factor in driving
people to hit the road for the holiday
Tuesday the national average stood at
273 a gallon that's down from Memorial
Day weekend this year and July 4th last
year but drivers in 12 states will pay
more than they did last week because
those states raised their gas tax
effective July 1st in Illinois it's up
19 cents a gallon
airports are going to be busy too the
TSA expects 12 point 1 million people
will go through its checkpoints between
today and Sunday with Sunday being the
busiest day nationwide so your best bet
for missing traffic is either leaving
after you finish watching CBS this
morning today or tomorrow morning
certainly Sunday the drive back will be
challenging and a reminder here drunk
driving deaths go up over the fourth of
July weekend it is one of the deadliest
weekend's on the roads Anthony not a
good forecast for my trip Chris but
thank you